[Music]
foreign
welcome back this is one of my favorite
lectures to give live because this
really synthesizes a lot of what we
learned up until this point about
linearizing non-linear dynamical systems
Computing the solutions of linear
differential equations and plotting
their phase portraits and looking at
their eigenvalues and eigenvectors so
I'm going to jump in and we are
basically going to be linearizing
non-linear Odes and then plotting their
phase portraits and I'm going to start
with a physical construct which is
called a particle in a potential well
so the idea is that we're going to
consider
a potential function literally like the
potential energy a potential
a potential V of x
and imagine dropping a bead or a marble
in that potential well
um and imagine
dropping
a
particle or a bead a particle
which I'm going to call a bead and I'll
tell you why in a minute a bead
um
X that can roll down the surface so we
have a potential surface so this is the
X Direction This is V of X it's
literally like the potential energy of
being at this height or this height or
this height so you can kind of imagine
you know maybe gravity is pulling you
down and you have different potential
energies at different at different
levels in this potential and we are
dropping a particle or a bead so I think
if this sometimes is a wire and I've got
a little bead that can slip on that wire
with no friction and it can move around
on that potential surface so our bead
and it has position X so position X
this bead can
can roll
or slide
down
this potential surface
okay words are not as important as the
picture the idea is that I have this
potential surface and I'm putting some
particle or some bead on this and it can
kind of roll around or slide around on
this potential and do its thing so if I
start with a little bit of energy or
potential energy here and I drop my bead
we assume it's going to oscillate that's
what a marble would do if there is no
friction if I have you know if I'm in
this well I will do the same thing and
if I have a little bit more energy this
is why I call it a bead because I don't
want it to fly off I want it to be
constrained to being on this kind of
wire surface it's also going to
oscillate around
okay and we're going to derive this
equations of motion from f equals m a
it's going to be a non-linear
differential equation and we're going to
linearize at different points
so the force
the force is
f equals m a okay obviously it's f
equals m a and the force from this
potential is always going to be the
negative gradient of that potential this
is just
um you know from kind of basic physics
the force is going to be proportional to
minus the gradient of the potential so
minus partial V partial X and this
basically says that if you know if if
this gradient is zero there's no force
moving it so it stays put this is a
fixed point when it's flat there's three
fixed points here and when it's uh when
the gradient's not zero then the force
is proportional to kind of how steep
this potential is so the steeper this
thing is partial D partial X the more
Force kind of accelerating this thing uh
down okay so the force is proportional
to the gradient minus gradient of the
potential and again if I have a positive
positive grad
V then that's going to be pulling me in
the negative Direction and if I have a
negative grad V that's going to be
pushing me in the positive direction
that's why I have this minus sign here
and so Newton's Second Law basically
says you know Newton's
Second Law we're very familiar with this
now Newton's second law says that X
double dot equals minus partial V
partial X I'm assuming that this bead
has mass 1 I don't want to deal with a
mass 2 or 5 or M this is for a mass 1
bead these are the equations of motion
okay so this is really really easy
um easy to deal with
now alternatively I could have derived
this uh not from Newton's law but from
the Euler LaGrange equations so maybe
I'll just show you um this is kind of a
little foray into how you get these
non-linear equations from physics
um
so
yeah maybe I'll um you know so so this
potential function because V in this
case this potential function would be
like a fourth order polynomial right
this thing looks like a fourth order
polynomial to me and so grad V is going
to be a third order polynomial and so X
double dot is going to be a third order
polynomial and X that's clearly
non-linear okay so this is how we get
non-linear differential equations would
be like a particle in this potential
well
so alternatively we could use the
lagrangian and could
derive
from the lagrangian LaGrange from
Lagrange
which I think is a little bit more
General than using Newton's Second Law
and so what we would do is we would
Define a kinetic energy and a potential
energy
so kinetic
energy of our particle is going to be
one half x dot squared so T equals one
half x dot squared okay this is just the
kinetic energy of this particle
we would Define the potential energy of
the particle so the potential
energy
we've already defined as you know V of x
okay and the lagrangian maybe I'll write
that in uh in blue
so the lagrangian this is from you know
LaGrange the great LaGrange
is this function L of both x and x dot
which is equal to my kinetic energy
minus my potential energy so it's this T
of x dot minus my V of X my kinetic
minus my potential that's how this is
defined
and we know that this is equal to you
know one half x dot squared minus V of X
that's my lagrangian
and so the Euler LaGrange equations are
a set of second order differential
equations that are
one of the most important sets of
equations in all of physics so the Euler
LaGrange equations
the Euler LaGrange
equations and these come from the
principle of least action which is
probably the most universal principle in
all of physics the Euler LaGrange
equations
uh essentially say
that the time derivative
of the partial derivative of L with
respect to x dot
minus the partial derivative of L with
respect to X
equals zero and again this is a
differential equation it is a second
order differential equation we'll find
that we're going to get you know X
double dots from this term here it's a
second order
ode that encapsulates the principle of
least action and the principle of least
action is probably the most universal
law in all of physics so physicists talk
about a grand unifying Theory I'd say
they already have one in the principle
of least action it applies to special
relativity general relativity classical
mechanics quantum mechanics
um you know Optics when light shines
through two different media it takes the
path at least the principle of least
action applies it takes the path at
least least resistance
um so this is super duper useful the
Euler LaGrange equation is the principle
of least action and you can apply it to
this very simple bead on a rotating hoop
and uh literally partial L partial x dot
this is the only term that has an x dot
so you know
um
partial L partial x dot is just
um using the power rule one you know I
get two times one half is one times x
dot this just equals x dot
which implies that DDT
of partial L partial x dot is X double
dot and similarly partial l
partial X is just
minus
partial V
partial X
um good
and so if I combine these I basically
have you know X
double dots
minus a minus partial V partial X is
plus partial V partial x equals zero
which of course implies that X double
dot equals minus partial V
partial X
now of course that's already what we had
from Newton's second law but the Euler
LaGrange equations are way way more
General so you can use this basic idea
to write down the equations of motion
for almost any system not just
mechanical systems quantum mechanical
systems relativistic systems if I had
you know my my pendulum here and I wrote
this down in terms of its angle Theta
and its angular velocity Theta dot I
could do the same thing I'd write down
the kinetic energy
is you know this thing has a length l
and a mass m so the kinetic energy T
would be one half m
L
squared theta dot squared okay that's
the kinetic energy of that system I
could write down the potential energy
it's probably something like V equals uh
you know m g cos
Theta maybe there's a minus sign here I
forget but you know I could write down
the potential and the kinetic energy for
this system plug them into the oil of
LaGrange equation and I will get the
equations of motion
um you know Theta double dot equals
minus sine
Theta right you can derive the equations
of motion for a double pendulum for
almost any mechanical system in almost
any physical system at all using these
oil LaGrange equations and the neat
thing is is that this always gives us
you know essentially a second order
system of Odes because Newton's Second
Law this is another way of stating
Newton's Second Law they're they're kind
of equivalent this is just maybe a more
powerful way of saying it
you're always going to get this uh this
kind of second derivative because of
this term here so these this always
gives you second order uh ordinary
differential equations and in general
they're going to be non-linear like this
sine Theta is a non-linear term here
because this potential function V this
you know uh grad V term here is
generally going to be a non-linear
potential it's going to have some weird
funky shape and so you're going to get
these non-linear terms in your second
order ode
okay so I think what I'm gonna do in the
next lecture is I'm going to take an
example of some potential probably
um you know V equals x squared over 2
minus X cubed over three something that
looks like
um
like that and we're going to derive the
differential equation x double dot
equals you know minus the graph of this
is minus X
plus x squared we're going to find its
fixed points we're going to linearize
about those fixed points and we're going
to draw the phase portrait this is going
to be a beautiful culmination of
everything we've done we can now analyze
non-linear differential equations that
come from a broad class of interesting
physical systems and we're going to
specifically linearize about the fixed
points here and here we're going to find
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of
those linearizations to classify their
stability and what the local Dynamics
look like and then we're going to be
able to draw these really rich phase
portraits showing what the global uh
structure of trajectories of the system
are so really really cool stuff that's
all coming up next so looking forward to
showing you that thank you
[Music]